I'll play he for goodbye world let's
play let's play something normal make
sure I can breathe wait he played Knight
f6 f6 I'm play Knight c3 that's a tricky
line idea of Bishop c5 I take on e5 d5
what's it takes e5 ok so the idea here
is Queen e2 6 no t4 wait a minute Bishop
d6 was Bishop d6 I feel like my opponent
might be prepared I can take on d5
[Music]
probably Castle back oh wait I haven't
develop my bishop yet hmm maybe D for
them and d4 could run into trouble
so maybe 93 scary position already d4
maybe d4 is fine at the night and then
Bishop III getting ready to queenside
castle yeah it's kind of scary let's
castle I guess Bishop takes h2 is a move
it's a weird move hmm f5 I'll play g4
band then there's Bishop b4 so maybe I
should retreat the night let's retreat
the Knight to c3 Bishop b4 probably
coming there before maybe Queens c4 I
have ideas now of g4 I want to plate
like g4 and Bishop g2 7 seems a little
bit slow and it's playable let's play g4
ship G - nice diagonal for the bishop
so maybe each for now push pons
yeah I'm feeling comfy f5 what f5 that's
so random have five so the bishop in
night support f5 maybe I could play
you'd start with a queen c4 check let's
play Queen c4 I mean black has idea of
playing I for almost chopping my bishop
I play wait this Bishop g5 I move Bishop
g5
hmmm trying to recall where everything
is well the play Bishop g5 that pins the
knight to the Queen so it does allow
that so I basically sack up on
man why am I so slow
rook 81 Brooke rook to e1 hitting the
night overtakes up to as a move Queen c7
wait what am i winning a piece now was
the rook on yet oh the rock went to
Yates earlier forgot about that okay
maybe now t5 try and fight
wait two minutes 21 seconds black four
minutes 13 seconds meant rosy 8 it's
probably a good move what to do
maybe each five triage five we might
under trading everything oh but if
Pontic z5 I take on c7 and taking on d5
I think I fork the recognition really 95
so I'm forking there's no Bishop g5
because the pawns on that floor wait oh
the pawns on g4 and I can't play f4 cuz
on passant takes with check so I should
play Keaney one well played well played
what should you look cookie one I guess
some down upon could be worse
so the bishops on g5 bishop on d7 pawn
and g4 believe I still have upon an f2
[Music]
this is very difficult position at some
point I might like on blindfold myself
and just try and survive this is not
looking so enjoyable it's a very strong
move
I wanna play see 4 and then rook I'll
see 4 it doesn't do anything productive
rook f8 so I've to is gonna fall my
bishop will be attacked back rank
problems I think it's time to look so I
probably couldn't survive this with it
even by looking ok let's look oh it is
five plus five oh I forgot I have a pawn
a three okay
I've opened my eyes no this is a really
difficult position I was getting hot in
the hoodie - I was never down upon
weights it's equal material oh I'm about
to lose a pawn though oh but I have
Ricky five oh maybe it's not so bad
Ricky five take sticks let's play rookie
five I mean okay White's so worse it's
not as bad as I thought though there's
actually some interesting tricks here
like if if rook takes F - that's so nice
being able to see everything I want to
play Knight c3 ninety-seven ideas
ninety-seven hitting the bishop and
unleashing hitting the pawn as well to
probably have to take it's still tricky
I can't do that hmm play those three
know what I wanted
route f1 check King V 2
roof f7 interesting it's interesting of
hoping that black takes if flag doesn't
take I have 96
G 396
room f6
I see for my bishop defends from a
distance g5
there should be eight rope d8 this is a
fight very much of the fights I know I
know I'm long time
I won't flag I'll try not to flag see
five good move
want to play this next Jesus
Bishop t5
and not sure where the rooks moving here
than 96 probably
might be coming back Bishop f6 King C
one looks playable
you should f6 check can't see one I
guess I don't need the center voice you
turn this off
Penta - oh that's a interesting room
[Music]
it's very devious move
I'm in trouble now
I can take the rook as g2 it's nice idea
I need some common calming music
[Music]
pretty sure when my king was on c1
bishops III was just winning no kind of
alive
there's perpetual
but I mean this should be losing but
we'll see what happens
interesting
defending defending knights a bit
overworked ooh
okay I'm attacking the bishop hey I'm
okay
I think I'm alive wow what an end game
this is gonna be a pong race
I think White's quicker might better be
quicker this is definitely winnable
getting some time there I've changed
really quickly it's - I'll have to be
careful I mean no I do this properly
maybe this move first slowing down g4
and preparing work before
yeah it's all about like accelerating
your pawns while at the same time
slowing down your opponent's pawns
[Music]
mmm here here here this is still very
tricky
well I'm inside the box though I can
walk my King in I think
[Music]
I'm close enough and now this
[Music]
waiting for this so I can meet okay I'm
ready to push my pawn now what is this
position
what is this what's going on Black's
gonna queen but all Queen to
what's going on oh my gosh
what is this so I queen if I queen don't
think I should Queen I should take the
rook
[Music]
this position I think I watched the win
but I still have hope to win this I have
to like walk my King to somewhere my my
king is so naked
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay let's not lose this because that
would be pretty bad
let's walk the King this way
[Music]
I'm going into the this corner feel like
that's my safest bet I give this Oh so
tricky
very tricky play this move I found a
square for my king where maybe I can
block with the rook next I'll block with
the rook this game is insane no more
checks right my queen controls the
square d5 I think I'm winning no more
checks
I found safety shelter what a game so
many different stages of this game it's
like a whole story so many plot twists
it's the nature of the increment just
keeps going and going
I thought I was winning I thought I was
winning until it was a draw I guess that
was the final plot twist good game
yeah Queen AJ was also a draw - well
they kinky I really thought it was
winning I even pointed out I controlled
d5 and well-played oh man
so that will probably go on YouTube not
sure what I'll call that night c8 with
gay marriage thanks knight c8 yeah that
was I mean that was just an emotional
rollercoaster
it started off blindfold and then it was
a matter of not losing that was
interesting opening to in Bishop d6 was
a nice move and then what happened okay
so this is a blindfold portion I thought
I was winning material I thought the
rook was on f8 i forgot moved to e8
and then I was so happy to like fork but
I forgot this was a move and then okay I
wanted to play this but then on to song
with check and eg we played a few times
before someone needs to help match Pro
is trying to donate I think there's a
donate command is there a donate command
there might be a donate command or a
support command but if we go forward
okay there is a point I think in this Oh
No maybe a support command in this
position I think this like Bishop c3
let's go to analysis board
let's turn off the sound - yeah moobot
chaired the low link the stream labs
link sound standard Bishop c3 would have
been amazing finish for black like
threatening meat and if I take the rook
then just g2 I can't stop the Queen I
mean maybe I would try and run that I
mean Queens and everything just Falls
was really unfortunate
I missed a rook fork later on wait I
miss her rook for ah Knight g4 I missed
my g4 oh man I wasn't even like paying
attention to that I was so excited to
play this move wait wait that's a
terrible move Bishop takes e7 what was I
thinking that's such a bad move
oh what a game I just dropped my rook
like instead of playing the rook fork
where it's like better for whites I just
played terrible move and then takes I
can we got to this endgame g2 and this
this should've been easier when I kind
of just collapsed maybe around here I
had to calculate I should probably just
push I assumed but I mean I was trying
to calculate its line push push push
push push push
okay maybe it's better like this is a
better version compared to what we got
in the game yeah this is a much better
version this takes takes I assumed maybe
it's still tricky I assume it's winning
we could ask table this Oh Kenny in the
chat
shout out to Kenny amazing game so this
is winning but how is it winning where
does the king go king c3
way distance wait so it takes it takes
about 30 moves to get out of the checks
okay this is like this this is a
actually really interesting table based
position where table base just solves it
but for a human to understand this okay
so I put the King on a one over P ones
winning rook could be one but how do I
escape the checks I have to walk off the
board like this that's so funny okay
eventually the King finds shelter so
this line that I'm playing there it's a
best line for both sides can't play
Queen g5 it's insane
okay Queen B 1 and finally yeah White's
just winning chess is tough chess is
really tough okay that will go on
youtube for the e2 people hope you guys
enjoyed that you can hit the subscribe
button I'll see you in the future
someday in the future please look at
rook takes g4 where was rook takes g4 o
maybe in this position no oh
rook takes g4 here oh so simple I should
have played that I should have played
Rock case G for threatening mates yeah I
was I was being cheeky with King f1
trying to prompt g3 for mates and then
wait it's winning Oh rook rook here
Chuck what's the difference rook meet
you chuck King H one push ah maybe this
move I assume be one oh it's already
drawn ah king of waking up to King H two
O king of three and the pawns pinned but
still takes oh yeah wait a minute okay
oh that's fascinating I Queen and
wherever black checks my King Oliver
spawn with discover check that's really
nice that's crazy
Cheska me so beautiful
no this is such an interesting position
with the double pawn race the two pawns
for each side
you